[Music]
on this sunday night consoling a
grieving community in the wake of
tragedy
u.s president joe biden and the first
lady visit uvalde texas we need help as
america's gun control debate 19 children
died 19 children died further divides
the country
gun violence spilling over the border
the majority of those firearms are
coming from the united states could
proposed canadian legislation save lives
here
two billion dollars in canadian aid to
ukraine but now the country's desperate
plea for the one thing it needs
immediately
a community in the democratic republic
of congo celebrates a unique christmas
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us u.s
president joe biden is in uvalde texas
tonight trying to comfort another
grieving community biden and the first
lady visited a memorial at robb
elementary school where 19 children and
two teachers were killed in last
tuesday's mass shooting the couple laid
flowers embraced staff members and
stopped in front of photos of the
victims saying each of their names out
loud
these condolence visits are becoming a
solemn ritual of biden's presidency it's
his second trip to the scene of a mass
shooting in less than two weeks heather
urex west is in uvalde tonight and
heather it's understandable that people
want to see action not just empathy
[Music]
yeah colleen this is of course the
memorial day weekend here in the u.s
people are using this opportunity to
come to you valde in order to pay their
respects people have come from all over
the region like the president to
remember the victims but there are many
who are also anxious to see changes made
cindy ochoa and catherine galinda garcia
are not from a valde but as fellow
southwest texas teachers they felt
compelled to be here i want to stand for
ms garcia and ms mireles who were the
fourth grade teachers that protected
their kids and died
i want to remember them and make sure
that they're never forgotten to know
that those teachers
acted as human shields to try to protect
those kids but it was off or not the
women are heartbroken but they are also
angry and afraid that the next time it
could be their classrooms their students
and so they have a message for the
president
during his time here i also don't want
him to go home
and to forget us because
it's it's really getting really bad so i
really want
a gun reform to happen at a growing
memorial outside robb elementary school
president joe biden and his wife laid a
bouquet of white flowers pausing to
remember the 21 people who died the
first lady taking a moment to touch each
child's photo
including ten-year-old jace luvanos who
recently lost his grandpa and loved to
make people laugh
but community members expressed
frustration as the president left mass
at the same church attended by fourth
grade teacher irma garcia and her
husband joe who two days after his wife
was shot and killed died of a heart
attack his family says he died of a
broken heart
at a service at that church saturday
night community members gathered
together in mourning uvaldi has a long
hard road ahead it's going to take a
very long time
the children involved will never heal
fully because there will be
posttraumatic stress from this forever
but many families are looking for
answers before they can even start to
heal today we heard that the federal
department of justice will launch an
investigation at the request of ivaldi's
mayor into the police his response to
tuesday's shooting
looking into why that response took so
long colleen
heather your ex west in uvalde texas
thanks heather there's been no u.s gun
legislation passed in 25 years and mass
shootings have become an almost daily
occurrence there americans are on edge
last night a stampede broke out at the
barclays center in brooklyn after people
thought they'd heard gunfire at a boxing
match at least 10 people were injured in
the chaos as jennifer johnson reports
frustrated americans are demanding
change
tension spilled over in this houston
restaurant as an angry patron confronted
senator ted cruz the texas lawmaker came
to the nra convention just days after
the mass shooting at robb elementary
school 19 children died 19 children died
it's on your hands angry protesters
greeted convention attendees
as americans send a clear message to
lawmakers that enough is enough with all
the shootings
and this one in new valley
just hit us really hard
we have 13 grandchildren between us
and
we can't imagine find a path forward
here connecticut senator chris murphy is
now talking with republicans about
passing two gun control proposals a red
flag law allowing law enforcement
officials to confiscate guns from people
who show signs of violence and stricter
background checks for gun buyers i think
there is something dying inside the soul
of this country when we refuse to act at
a national level shooting after shooting
murphy says his state has never
recovered from the sandy hook elementary
school mass shooting that left 20
children and six staff members dead but
democrats need 10 republicans to vote
with them something that hasn't happened
in decades when it comes to gun control
i believe that those are two pieces of
legislation that have overwhelming
public support
we can get it done if the senate has the
political will to do it polls show well
over half of american voters want
stricter gun control laws and they are
demanding action a second march for our
lives protests will be held in
washington june 11th the first was four
years ago after the mass shooting at a
parkland florida high school that left
17 dead so we're getting back out there
and calling on our u.s congress to
actually care this time around because
children are dying since that florida
high school tragedy the senate has
refused to pass any gun control laws but
americans are hoping after the massacre
at robb elementary things will be
different this time
jennifer johnson global news washington
u.s gun control advocates often look to
canada as an example of a system that
works but over the years gun violence
has been on the rise in this country too
despite what already seems like tougher
measures to combat it as catherine
ercart reports more federal legislation
may be on the way in the midst of
growing calls to do more
metro vancouver police continue to deal
with gang shootings as do members of the
toronto police service and in recent
years canadians have witnessed
large-scale tragedies
shootings like this one in maple ridge
british columbia have become a regular
occurrence in many parts of canada
despite having tougher gun laws than in
the united states the problem is here
and it has been here for several years i
often comment the fact that the reason
why we have such
a significant amount of gang violence
given the canadian culture here is the
simple access to firearms and the
majority of those firearms are coming
from the united states a new statistics
canada report shows firearm related
homicides jumped 11 percent from 2013 to
2020.
the majority of those crimes involved
handguns
new federal firearms legislation is
expected to be introduced on monday i'm
not going to preempt what minister
mendocino
has in
as a matter of cabinet confidence
but i think i think it's fair to say
that this is on the top of the prime
minister's agenda
will new legislation make a difference
bc's former solicitor general believes
it could this has worked for other
countries such as britain and australia
where in fact they had a couple of
serious incidents of mass shootings and
they got in front of it and they showed
that there was a reduction in this a
reduction in gun crimes would
undoubtedly be welcomed by canadians but
details of the legislation are yet to be
released and would still face the
parliamentary process before becoming
law
catherine ercart global news vancouver
to ukraine now where the war in the east
is intensifying today president vladimir
zelinsky visited troops on the front
lines in the harkiev region
this is his first official appearance
outside the kiev region since russia
began its full-scale invasion february
24th the area is littered with destroyed
buildings and burned out vehicles
according to zielinski's chief of staff
31 percent of the area is occupied by
russia and just 5 percent of the
northeastern region has been taken back
and warm welcomes today as a second
chartered flight from ukraine arrived in
canada 306 ukrainians fleeing the war in
their homeland touched down at
montreal's international airport at
eleven o'clock today flying out from
poland after being approved for
emergency travel to canada
canada has committed nearly two billion
dollars in aid to ukraine but president
zielinski is once again calling for more
weapons it comes as russian artillery
and airstrikes threatened to turn the
tide of the war jeff simple has more
from ukraine
this sporting goods store in western
ukraine has transformed into a
humanitarian hub packed full of
donations food and medical supplies but
even more than humanitarian aid what
they really need is tactical equipment
these are the special tools which make
our soldiers and troops more efficient
it helps save lives
body armor and helmets drones and
thermal imaging cameras that can detect
body heat to help spot a hidden enemy
items desperately needed on the front
lines we have probably
250 requests right now cueing piling up
which we are trying to cover this
shipment of tactical gear came from
canada donated by a group founded by
canadian veterans who served in ukraine
that's what we do is the non-lethal aid
but unlike traditional aid the group
says the export permit process for this
equipment has been painfully slow
this shipment of supplies for ukraine
sat in a warehouse near toronto for two
months waiting for permission from
ottawa lives are at stake with every day
that passes that it takes for these
permits to be to be issued but while
slow in sending canadian hardware is
being deployed across ukraine
a canadian aerospace company donated
dozens of these surveillance drones
they're able to take just normal video
images either still or video in high
resolution
the operator also has the ability to
look at thermal imaging and it would
also be
geo-located so it will have gps
information embedded in that picture
those details on russian positions are
then relayed to teams on the ground
including this ukrainian brigade their
anti-tank weapons hitched to the back of
this canadian amphibious all-terrain
vehicle
it allows us to be mobile with our
weapons and makes it easier to hide he
says we also use it to evacuate people
as russian forces have fled they've
littered areas with landmines this
specialized demining kit built with
non-magnetic materials to avoid
triggering an explosion was also sent
here by the canadian veterans group they
could actually help the frontline units
save lives save homes save people from
the trauma rethinking the definition of
humanitarian aid in a time of war
jeff semple global news la viv ukraine
coming up why family members of the nova
scotia shooting are boycotting mass
casualty commission testimony
and marine mystery getting to the bottom
of why whales are dying in the waters
off montreal
the public inquiry into the murders of
22 people in nova scotia in 2020 is the
subject of renewed skepticism tonight
most family members have begun
boycotting the testimony of rcmp
decision makers claiming the mass
casualty commission overseeing the
public hearings is shielding the
mounties from full accountability ross
lord reports
having protested in the streets in order
to get a full public inquiry these
families and their supporters are once
again demonstrating against what some
call an expensive waste of money we're
26 plus million dollars
how close are we going to be to the
truth really the breaking point the mass
casualty commission exempting two
upcoming witnesses rcmp decision makers
from cross-examination by lawyers
representing most of the 22 families
lawyers have also launched class action
lawsuits against the rcmp and the nova
scotia government it's extremely
infuriating to sit there and just watch
it all happen the daughter of murder
victim tom bagley questions whether the
inquiry is truly independent we did not
fight for a review we were fighting for
an inquiry and
pretty much what we got was a review so
it's very disheartening families are not
the only ones questioning the decision
to confine the maudi's testimony to
pre-recorded zoom calls only certain
questions in a very um controlled
situation or controlled context so that
the rcmp
can
manage
not only their police legitimacy but
manage the image and the brand of the
rcmp there's a great concern and always
has been a concern that the rcmp will
not be pull put before full scrutiny and
that to some extent some of the worst
errors may not be revealed the killer
escaped from a tiny neighborhood in
puerto pick disguised as a mouty through
a road left unguarded by the rcmp
despite a rampage that went on for 13
hours an emergency alert to the public
was never issued are you familiar with
the alert ready situation or system in
nova scotia and its availability to rcmp
sources on april of uh april 18th 19th
of 2020
i had no knowledge of it at that time
there's more frustration the commission
suggesting the rcmp should be more
upfront about improvements made since
the massacre we are finding out about
things the rcmp did on an ad hoc basis
by chance coming from witnesses like
yeah there's now a
a second risk manager can be brought in
many families are now boycotting the
inquiry leading many to wonder if a
successful outcome is still possible
ross lord global news
ahead wrong turn at montreal the search
for answers after another whale is found
dead
you're watching global national
montrealers were mesmerized earlier this
month when minky whales were spotted in
nearby waters but now one of them has
died and it's the second whale to die in
the area in the past two years as dan
spector reports scientists are now
trying to understand what's killing
these wayward animals
in early may montrealers were captivated
by a minke whale that appeared near the
city's old port
a few days later a second one appeared
two whales hadn't been seen here
together in a century impressive to
watch but experts knew this was not good
i was not very optimistic the whales
were hundreds of kilometers from their
saltwater home near the gulf of st
lawrence with little food and the
rushing currents of fresh water taking a
toll on their bodies
clearly disoriented said this scientist
monitoring the whales it's like a trap
and they don't seem to figure out the
way to turn back and go back to the to
the estuary on thursday a grim discovery
a three meter long minke whale that
scientists say is likely one of those
spotted in montreal found dead by a
fisherman 40 kilometers east of the city
it was a young animal we estimate his
age to be between one or two years old
two years old
it was male over there wow
two years ago a humpback whale appeared
in montreal drawing big crowds and
sparking joy as the city was battered by
covid but that story didn't have a happy
ending either that whale also died
possibly because it was struck by a boat
are they looking for food is there a
change in the salinity of the water that
kind of
attract them a little bit upstream i
don't i don't know on friday the minke
whale was transported to the university
of montreal's veterinary school for an
autopsy stefan lapp performed the
procedure and said the whale was not hit
by a boat but he could not determine the
exact cause of death mineral
deficiencies related to skin damage
caused by freshwater algae are one
possibility if the sodium level is
really low the animal could could could
just uh a faint and it would drown
as for the second whale lag said he
won't be surprised if he's soon doing
another autopsy but on the bright side
the scientist says more whales taking
the wrong turn to montreal is a sign
that whale populations are on the rise
then specter global news montreal
next a merry christmas in may the unique
holiday in the democratic republic of
congo
global news has partnered with canadian
ngo journalist for human rights to help
train journalists beyond canada as part
of those efforts our mike armstrong is
in the democratic republic of congo
mentoring reporters in its capital and
he recently did a story with local
journalists there on a very special
celebration with a unique take on
christmas
[Music]
they turned up by the thousands for what
isn't a day that's like their christmas
the kimbanguist religion may 25th is the
actual christmas
the day they believe jesus christ was
born
the provincial head of the church says
based on their research december 25th
isn't jesus's birthday it's basically
just a date that caught on
kimbang wisdom is a religious movement
that sort of split off from christianity
they follow the bible and believe jesus
was the son of god but they also
believed that in the early 1900s jesus
was reincarnated in fact here just west
of kinshasa in what was then the belgian
congo
again the reincarnated jesus was also
born on may 25th
this man says the bible predicted christ
would return and that happened his new
name
[Music]
now the church says they have about 22
million believers around the world most
of them in the democratic republic of
the congo but they do have followers in
canada their groups in toronto and
montreal the kembangus church is based
in a city west of the capital but this
celebration in kinshasa is one of the
this biggest says she came with her
entire family and that people came from
every region of the province
the church doesn't believe in drinking
alcohol smoking or dancing although
music and marching are a big part of
their celebrations
one thing we were also told by believers
is that they hope to spread the
teachings of their church and the
reincarnated jesus and that someday
their date for christmas replaces the
one most people go by mike armstrong
global news kinshasa democratic republic
of the congo
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie we
leave you tonight with a tribute to
rockabilly singer ronnie hawkins who
died this morning at the age of 87 after
a long illness
[Music]
originally from the u.s ronnie hawkins
moved north in 1958 to make canada his
home often referred to as the father of
canadian rock and roll he inspired a
generation of rock musicians from all
over thanks for joining us good night
[Music]
[Music]